so this is how it looks let's actually
play this out um I know this is not that
but I'm going to draw some grass for you
okay because that's the easiest way to
illustrate what's actually going to
happen so I'm going to draw these kinds
of graphs you might like to draw a few
as well what I've got on the vertical
axis is the signal okay like a sound or
something like that and on the
horizontal axis I'm gonna have time so
there's the start of my signal and
here's you know where progressions okay
so what my things look like what's the
what's the carrier signal will be some
agreed-upon um kind of signal like for
us it's that hum at a particular turn
you pick it up your recognizer it might
look like this okay and when the
computer who wants to transmit data
looks at the bus right it looks at the
medium and it sees this it knows great
there's a carrier signal I can send some
data okay
and send some done if of course it was
just a flat line right it would know
okay something's wrong there must be an
error alright and I can't send on it
what does it look like when it sends
some data well we're talking about zeros
and ones right so let's say it looked
like this
so there's a signal okay and off it gets
sent that's all fine the signal ends and
it goes back to the carrier soon
so far so good okay but what happens if
there are two different nodes okay
and they both sense the carrier signal
they both hop on and they see this so
then like sweet
I can send but they both send at exactly
the same time okay why is this a problem
now by the way I said exactly the same
time because if someone has started
sending a signal first right there
didn't send it at the same time say you
are sending and this is what I meant I
want to send when you're sending this is
what I see so it's a bit like you know
at home right if you've got multiple
phones connected home phones connected
to the same line and you're like I need
to call my friend so you pick up the
phone but you don't hear the data and
you hear someone else talking you're
hearing an actual signal right then you
know if I start pressing buttons nothing
will happen right it won't actually
transmit because no carrier signal okay
so problems start up when two people
pick up the phone at exactly the same
time they both hear the carrier signal
so they both think cool I can transmit
are we on the same page dafuq really
cooking all right now what happens when
two people go at the same time
okay well the signals not going to look
like this okay because two people are
adding signals at the same time the
resultant signal will look sort of
nonsensical
okay it won't follow the rules of
abnormal signal which is nice and sort
of orderly
okay we're busy rows and ones interview
all kinds of weird things which it's not
expecting okay so what's going on one or
both of the Nerds will sense this is not
right this is not what was meant to be
sent okay all right so what they do is
they send out a signal a particular
signal like say a very long break okay
someone will realize a counter stop
right because it's not signal I wanted
to
and someone else will say okay look I'm
going to say on a CV which basically
says it's a bit like a whistle everyone
stop everyone be quiet okay because
obviously we're not getting across our
messages
someone needs to wait their turn okay
someone needs to make their phone call
first and then the other person will do
it and that's what this kind of means a
signal over here it's a Shh stop wait
now what happens after that well at home
what you can do is you know after you
both realize you've both tried to die at
the same time right you can say hey hang
up you wait my phone calls more
important so you have a discussion with
these people right who you had a
collision with and then you'll come to
an agreement over you know how you can
someone is going to go first and then
can you just wait 10 minutes and then
the other person will go right but the
computers the nodes on our network they
have no such luxury why not why can't
they do that why can't they just talk to
each other and say hey can you just wait
for 10 minutes why can't they do it yeah
okay so number one I they you know
they're very Western we're talking
simple devices here right so they're not
they don't have really intelligence per
se we need something automatic if it can
be just done okay so number one there's
this you probably requires a lot of
intelligence number two how did they
communicate how would they have that
discussion well for us they would you'd
hang up the phone and then you'd go over
to them and then you'd talk to them and
say hey stop being a jerk let me use the
phone first right now what what are we
assuming we're assuming there's another
medium a second medium not the phones
which are messed up but in our case it
would be air I guess that's the other
medium we can use but here for these
nodes there's no other medium right so
it would be a bit like at this point
here if they're trying to talk to each
other and say oh wait no you wait and
all that kind of thing right um they're
going to cause the same problem they're
just going to cause more data collisions
when they talk to each other okay so we
need some kind of automated proceed
that's already imagining which can work
on this network here okay without the
need for an extra medium so what do they
do what they do is at this point here
after all of that garbage is finished
okay the two different nodes they wait a
random time okay
so this is set in the protocol right
they look at their own computers clock
and their kicker in time like say five
milliseconds or ten seconds or whatever
it is okay and then they both wait the
random time so the carrier signal will
return okay and then after the random
time they start transmitting again okay
so say mine was five milliseconds and
yours was ten okay I wait from my five
seconds to elapse and then I start to
send the message that I really wanted to
say okay now after your 10 milliseconds
right my message has already started
okay so then you can't jump on and
listen because you've gotten a carrier
signal like you had before so you just
wait until I'm finished with the carrier
signal resumes and then you go off to
your message does that make sense now
what would happen if at this point after
you've waited to get your case you'll
again we get another data Chris what
would happen it just repeats okay and
this happens a lot okay this happens
hundreds of times in a normal data
transaction okay but can you see this is
the procedure that nodes executed this
is what they go through this is their
process when this simultaneous
transmission to get that right has to at
the same time out of data from multiple
nodes okay and I just had to if there
was 20 right the same thing would happen
at this point
all 20 of them would wait a random time
okay and then hopefully the first person
who you know has a unique time they
would start and then the rest of us
would lose the kerosene so we wouldn't
transmit okay